皆さんに質問です
あなたは夢を叶えたいときやも一を達成したい時何をしますか
多くの人の答えは
流行種という言葉が出てくると思います
どんなに努力をしても夢を叶えなかった時や目標が達成できなかったとき
8夢をあきらめかけてはいませんか
今はこの中でもあるのでその夢死体をミュージないかけてはいませんか
今日は実際に私が経験した話にすぎませんが
そんな
夢をあきらめかけている人にしないかけている人にこそ聴いて欲しいと思います
私は現在合唱部に所属しています
私が中学生だったころ中学のがすぐ超
させていただけました
の私には夢がありました
すれば
合唱部のメンバーと一緒に全国大会に出場し
賞をいただくことでした
私は幼い頃から
夢や目標達成したいときは人一倍努力しなさいというふうに教えられてきたので
私は一生懸命練習をしてきました
そして結果発表の日
私は絶対人国大会に試乗できる
賞をもらうことができるというふうに思っていました
しかし結果は全国大会出場どころかその一個前のブロック大会にしろ
出場ができなかったのです
私はこの結果を聞いた瞬間
悔しさより驚きの方が大きかったと思います
なぜならば駅レーヌ先輩方の練習姿を見て
アナ風に私も努力をすればおのずと先輩方のように
賞をいただくことができるんだと思っていたからです
私は愕然としました
私の中での常識が一気に崩れ落ちたのです
私は
どんなに努力をしても無駄なんだ
何をしても意味ないことなのだと思うようになってしまいました
私はなぜ
全国大会に出場ができなかったのか一生懸命考えました
しかしどんなに考えても行くつく先はいつも願っているなことばかりで
何をやっても仕方がないことなのだというふうに思いました
色々考えてたある日私はあることに気がつきました
夢を簡単に叶えられるものではないし
努力だって必ずしも報われるわけではないのだと気づきました
考えていることはねは目立てるかと思いますが
これは私にとってとても大きな気づきでした
簡単に叶えられないものだからこそ人は努力ができるし
その努力が報われるために全力を尽くすことができると考えたからです
あれ昔ですよねー
夢を叶えるための端の努力が必ずしも報われない努力だったら
それって意味ないですよね
そんな努力だったら一向に夢を叶えられないじゃないですか
ような疑問を持った人もいると思います
安心してください第中です
努力は決して見ないものではありませんしん
夢だって叶えることができます
それにはちょっとした工夫が必要なのでですごい今から皆さんに
3つ
他の人には内緒で
お話ししたいと思います
一つ目
私は次の大会までに自分の夢を一緒に話すことにしました
人に話すことによって自分の夢が舞台化され
夢を叶えなくちゃいけないといい意味で自分を追い詰めることができたのです
話し始めた当初は
自分に自信がなかったため
そんなまた夢のような話できるわけない
とか
そんなことやったって無駄だよというふうに言われるのが怖かったので
ためらうこともありました
ですが自分の夢を話してる罪
どんどん自信が出てきました
そして
実現するまでの自分がイメージしやすくなったのです
確かに不安はありました
もし失敗してしまったらどうしよう
全国大会に行けなかったらどうしようというふうに思った日もありました
ですが
まで大会の結果なんてわからない
当日にならないと
何があるか誰も分からないのに
自分で自分の限界を決めているのはなんでもったいないことをしているのだろうと
気づいたのです
当然私の思い通りにならない日はたくさんあげました
ですが私は
無理に気持ちを切り替えようとはせずに
特等打ち込むことにしました
これでを例に挙げて説明します
羽根は上からして押せば恐れを高く飛び上がると思います
人計も同じで気持ちが押しつぶされれば
押しつぶされるほど
その後首上がれるチャンスだと思ったのです
じゃあ顕著チャンスにという言葉ではありませんがその状況から大ハズレ力がすごく出
てくるのかなと思いました
そして打ち込んでしまったり悔しかったりするのはきっと自分がちゃんと頑張っている
証なんだなーと思うようになりました
二つ目
私はノー所に自分の気持ちを書くことにしました
人は
家に泊め混みすぎると
ストレスを抱えてしまいます
私の場合
ストレスを溜め込みすぎてと一緒にぶつかってしまったり物にぶつかる
悪い癖があったのでそれを防ぐためにもノートに書くことにしました
なぜノートに書くことが良いのか
これも例を挙げて失明をします
例えば携帯ありますよね
この中のデータが多くなってしまうと
その後のデータが保存できなくなっちゃいと思います
人間も同じで
家に溜め込みすぎると使い物にならなくなってしまうのです
使い物にならなくなってしまうというのは
頭の中が整理できずに
思考が止まってしまうということです
携帯にはマイクロ sd というデータを保存性ダメのものがありますが
人間には人間用のマイクロ sd は残念ながら開発されていないので
納富各書き込むことがベストだと私は思います
私が書いてノートには
とても辛いことや
苦しかったことが書かれているので
私はそのノート闇の音と呼んでいました
今でも見返すときがあるのですが
恥ずかしい内容ばかりなので
とても読んでて
グラフィックがこんなに大変だったんだなとか
こんなこと思ってたんだなとか思うようになっているのですがそれもいい思い出なので
今でも大切に保管しています
そして最後3つ目
開所を忘れないこと
感謝って努力とは一見全く関係ないようなことだと思いますが
実は鑑賞することがとても大事なのです
私の場合合唱部に所属していたので
合唱は団体戦です
その団体の雰囲気が悪いとやはりうまくいかないと思います
なので私は周りの雰囲気をとても気にするように知っていました
そのために私は感謝をすることでその後
明るくすることにしました
が当時の私は
少し照れくさいっていうのもあったのか
なかなか鑑賞言い出せずに言いました
なので私は挨拶代わりに
マルマルちゃん昨日は一緒に練習してくれてありがとうとか
小さなことでもいいので
一つ一つ感謝するようにしました
私は次の大会までいい
自分の夢を人に腹すっ
自分の気持ちはノートにすぐに書き込む
人に感謝を伝えるということを意識して過ごすようにしました
前回の大会から約1カ月後
私たちは今年度最後の大会に挑みました
結果はなんと金賞
とっても嬉しかったです
さらに嬉しいことに全国大会への出場を決定しました
私は
夢をあきらめないで本当に良かったなと心からそう思いました
私には夢があります
それは今日私が話したことが一人でも多くの人の心に届くことです
自分自身で見つけた夢である限りは自分を信じて欲しいと思います
私の言っていることは
きれいごとかもしれません
ですが夢を叶えるためには
どれだけ自分のことを信じられるか
どれだけ住むを夢に対して熱意を持ってるかが大事だと思います
きっと皆さんの夢に対してあれこれ言ってくる人がいると思いますがその人の思うが
ままにならず自分だけは夢を信じられる人で言ってください
もし簡単に諦められるような夢であればそれは本当の意味での自分の夢ではないと思い
ます
同市自分なんてできっこないなんて思った瞬間
負けです
でもその夢
諦めたとしたら公開しませんか
絶対に後悔しませんか
後悔すると思うんだったらあきらめない方がいいと思います
夢をかなえるのは大変です苦しいです
つらいです
でも
きっとその夢は自分を強くしてくれるでしょう
私は育ち良い気持ちを持った人の夢を応援したいと思います
一緒に頑張りましょう
ありがとうございますか